wait he did a thing but it didn't do a
thing it said you left or something
leave
it's a lying bastard that's what it is
what are you oh I gotta hit the accept
button no I was thought it was
accounting really you didn't do that you
shut your mouth you are a guest here
what do I do here there's God's Jude
choose one choose which one looks
coolest to you what ooh
Cupid yeah that's the coolest to me hell
yeah
guest of the mole yeah all the fingers
gonna go crazy cuz I'm the god of love
okay I have a tiny little two-inch bow
and you have a 13 foot long scythe how
is this oh you're a mighty never mind
yes okay oh look at me that's so cute
hey move what do I do well all my
abilities are heart based India gonna do
oh my what did I just do what is that
hmm can I heal you guys yeah yes Oh back
when I played World of Warcraft those
the healers do I mean this is perfect
for me yeah blasters you guys sorry
Steve sticking my bolt ah I can't do
anything all my things are ready doubt
huh big guy
the guy he's got a very small tiny
itty-bitty so it's okay no don't worry
if you get you only get money if you get
the last bit something like that not ask
I left it to get you where are nice
shooting arrow or Whammer is shooting
hurts
you want me lb you've left me to die
Thanatos you've left me to die I'm sorry
you left
markiplier to die I'm gonna spray them
with my red-hot love is that what I'm
doing yes yes banger oh yeah we're
killing these easy BOTS we're doing
great guys I did not mean to do that
yea-ah why don't you land on my hand
when I'm dead wait where's what
where's my gold like where don't I get
money for this yes it's in the bottom
right corner but I only have like 250 if
I die do I lose my gold now oh well then
why do I have so no gold Oh has it been
auto buying uh items for me if you have
unable then yes oh that's awesome
or not really probably that makes a
Robin it's not long at all
shut up it for you who's just learning
cuz it'll just do what you want it to do
mmm-hmm
oh well I'm gonna say it's awesome and
I'm awesome for having it on and anyone
who disagrees with me is gonna get
kicked from the call
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh you're on your own bro
let me if you like my epic one three and
five I'm assuming that means I'm number
one I've gotten three kills and they've
cowered in fear five times who are we
gonna win this we're gonna win oh no I'm
in our I knew that
Wow I think we're beating him pretty
hard
Jesus is a Minotaur stop stop do it aft
Tommy enough let's go all you can do is
run and once you leave the base it will
stop chasing you oh oh watch me yeah
yeah yeah go oh no I didn't they'll have
one killing four billion assists oh
don't let me do anything
Cupid once just inject them with my
red-hot love hello there Minotaur hello
we're gonna win g-guys Gee Gee Gee Gee
that's that thing that they stay after
it is match right next day after you and
go to hell if you lose just remember
you're gonna be broadcasted to thousands
and thousands of people to see your most
embarrassing lot they accept they expect
me to lose but you guys have no excuse
prepare yes yeah ladies wait I'm Cupid
okay mine is just the best your bird
again
I was totally random right holy random
yeah it just gave me Cupid no there's
gonna be the best are you going to suck
no gonna be bad so what do we do
don't go to the town holy oh sorry
yester I was just going I was leading
the way they're waiting for pinions I'm
gonna go after him yeah I do that mark
bastard gotta go
he was gogit Kiwis go get it I got it
wow that hurt ah wait I got him with
love oh I hit all like wow I was
actually very good opening oh thank you
thank you okay so oh my god bodies just
fell from the ceiling should I be
concerned about that
no you should not be yeah
they're just the menu that no one hasn't
asked about they'll write Wow Wow Hades
No
Hades doh are we winning yet I can't
tell what's going on hey yeah wait was
that good
did we kill before yeah you meters gonna
die yeah no he's not going to die oh
whoa oh you guys died are you bad and I
will kill you miracle day good I'm gonna
die I need you bad Hey oh oh well no I
guess desk if I'm bad cuz they already
know the answer mark I should let you
know now that you can't return to your
base on this one
what oh well I wasn't gonna anyway to
power that ok attack now packing then
boom I did I did a thing whoa oh yeah
whoa
proxy 87 or you could thank you I I was
asking a question I didn't know good
doctor you good thank you
no you're not good haha I got one of
their hearts to explode I think oh oh I
got some Hey
I was the cracker God wanna go oh I made
it yeah I get to eat my own hearts
what's this potion looking thingy in the
sea bar uh that it is a greener
blue-green its haloth I'm drinking it
that didn't do Sh
oh it's loves over time oh that's stupid
where's in the air course incoming uh uh
why is he there that's not something I'm
gonna fall in one of us hey he was
coming after me oh he was coming after
me I gotta kill oh yeah oh yeah there's
that good they left cuz they're so bad
oh yes they get angry and leave okay ah
yeah well the guys yeah yeah guys aren't
happy here with me how do you guys tear
the worst you may play good but you
celebrate poorly well we're gonna win
this guy's murderer
now don't get cocky you still lose it
great leader everyone yeah that's right
thank you
you're just so good at games so you know
a lot to see what made us win this game
like you teamwork Oh none do us damage
business wow we're wiping Oh lottery
baby no rents I'm gonna right
I'll save you know it's got a cover so
we're gonna get me no get a polka
material go get him yeah I did that
right oh no you mirror oh I needed to go
back to baste anyway I'd too much
respawn in 30 seconds this is awful
all hate he's about to get his ass
kicked by you mere the ice thing won't
happen we're gonna win this guys look
like you guys are sucking ass now that
I'm good when did Santa Claus get here
don't you know this is a nice level here
in the doors bold is to know that a
clause others already patients for you
they see it down a lot of health that
guy has a lot of oh when they die is it
like legal edges where they get the
golden what's a registered game no they
could do the baggage out because they
feared your awesome power they saw Cupid
coming and then they quit it just like a
tiny bells oh but if we do this again
I'm not gonna be Cupid there's a chance
you know Robin but on the screen
what do I do when dead oh it hurts it's
dark in here
okay so we're supposed to charge in
there and get them yeah three two one go
go get them gets it screw you guys we're
you didn't do it
ah proposing literally man good mine
we're all guy uh that didn't seem to
work out so well you do okay those
creeps dad go go down no don't go
I don't know I don't know if we did I
didn't see there was lots of flashes of
light I didn't know what happened
hmm angry laughs Brad don't forget gasps
Christmas yes to run away not for me yes
barrel doing nice yeah we killed
everyone everyone